c'est lui les geeks comme neuve sur la
toile alors aujourd'hui on se fait un
casse-tête des il ya une boîte dès
qu'ils existent et que j'ai déjà eu dans
les mains et que je sais ouvrir parce
qu'il suffit d'en fait de tourner dans
le sens des chiffres du day ce qui est
pas le cas de celle ci celle ci c'est un
vrai des dans le sens où petit le petit
fact que vous ne savez pas mettre la
somme de deux faces d'un des faits
toujours celle derrière le sicilien 1
derrière le 5 bien le deux dernières le
3 il ya le 4 ce qui n'était pas le cas
de la boîte de thé est d'ailleurs
commencé cette particularité on peut
faire des petits tours de magie
mentalisme avec ça puisque bon c'est
toujours quel est le chiffre de l'autre
côté ça vous dit que je vous apprenne un
tour avec l'ailé tu as dit moi je les
commentaires parce que je le connais
vraiment un truc ou alors je le ferai
dans l'hippocampe ou ou ailleurs où je
sais pas bref je m'égare
aujourd'hui mercredi 6 heures du matin
comme tous les mercredis en ce moment un
casque est sur la chaîne se veut pas
dire qu'il ya pas d'autres vidéos qui
casse tête ça faut être abonné ou à
vrak-tv la cloche ça sorte d' autres
jours de la semaine à 6 heures on sait
jamais à l'intérieur de cette boîte vous
entendez
stand by il va falloir la faire sortir
la faire sortir par l'un des trous j'ai
même pas fait la phase d'exploration je
veux dire j'ai ouvert le casse tête et
j'ai vu qu'à un troc est plus grosse que
les autres c'est le 1
ça se voit très clairement on le voit
très bien 1 est plus gros que le 2 il
faut trouver n'importe quand si j'ai
peur comme bojan ça sorte et que je sais
que tu sais qu'il sera résolu comme sa
nouvelle donne
je parle à loïc comme temps parce que
oui loïc est là et loïc était là la
semaine dernière dans la vidéo vous avez
pas vu mais allez ici si vous l'avez
ratée du coup il faut libérer cette
bille j'ai du malade déjà l'avoir où
elle est actuellement allez juste ici en
fait c'est une bille vraiment
transparente vous la ferez bien voir
qu'on aura réussi à la sortir si j'y
arrive et elle a un tout petit truc à
l'intérieur tu as je suis la plus comme
un simple énoncé ben ils vont bien et je
laissais d'yvon son déplacement la halle
et sur le bord du 2 bref quoiqu'il
arrive
comment ça marche ça vous êtes à oued
d'accord ok c'est hyper intéressant
en fait je vois par les troupes avant
que trop du 2 je vois par le trou opposé
du 5 c'est vraiment tout droit mais le
trou du 1 que deux cas là vous voyez du
bois à l'intérieur de ce trou là ça veut
dire que ça ne peut pas passer en direct
du 6au un le 5 je vois du bois le 3
joies du bois le deux donc c'est pas
possible le 4 c'est pas possible
rien donc je pense que la bille devra
passer par le 5 ou 2 3 pour arriver aux
impasses que le 1 ça je peux pas vous
faire voir déjà à l'oeil nu c'est
compliqué mais grosso modo je vois que
le jour la lumière elle entre par là
donc il doit y avoir un coude qui part
du 3
c'est ça donc il y avait en train de le
résoudre et un coude qui part du 3 et
qui va jusqu'au 1 comme un petit tunnel
donc j'imagine que le 3 ici il ya un
moyen d'y accéder
je pense le moyen d'y accéder c'est par
le ciss ici sauf que là ça fait un
tunnel qui continue comme ça et ça donc
il faudrait l'emmener au milieu du cices
je pense à peu près ce niveau là
pour ensuite ensuite faire quoi ensuite
le faire passer là dans le 3 mai sans
trop le faire avancer parce que sinon il
va et les siens faisant très avancée
parce qu'après il va passer dans leur
bon ben voilà en théorie j'ai résolu
[Musique]
théorie en pratique ça va pas être la
même bon avant de commencer la théorie
mais dans la pratique parce que la
théorie elle tient la route mais je suis
sûr je dois rien quand même
je serai en dédicace à boulogne début
décembre au salon du livre si vous
voulez venir et la tournée spectacle les
prochaines dates c'est c'est à mulhouse
c'est à marseille c'est à dijon et c'est
à enghien et tout le reste d'autres
villes et ces villes là vous avez un
lien dans la description
ok donc déjà l'habiller où a priori elle
va être en bas oui je la vois aller là
bon ok allez sur le 4 c'est très dur de
vous faire voir exactement ce que je
vois force est donc j'ai dit qu'il
fallait que je l'amène aussi ce cas par
exemple en faisant ça il est aussi ce
les il est ici la la la la la petite
bulle donc je me suis pour l'emmener aux
3 il faut que j'arrive à le lan menées
ici
d'abord si je fais ça ok ça c'est bon là
il est ici donc mon but c'est de
l'amener là et je pense vraiment en
théorie du coup ce sera une vidéo très
rapide mais que si j'arrive à le ramener
ici
après que je la mets là je sais pas trop
comment après je te récupérer le tunnel
où je vois la lumière qui vient de ce
côté là du 3
ah oui d'accord ok larnack qu'en fait
elle vient elle vient d'ici que c'est
extrêmement dur de la faire passer de là
à là parce que ça va directement là
cette caméra là va pas beaucoup servir
parce que je suis obligé de mener comme
ça les amis bassine monsieur ce possible
ça oh [ __ ] j'y suis déjà quoi j'étais
en train de me dire il faudrait mettre
action pour le bloquer donc là là je
suis je vais vraiment essayer de ne pas
perdre le truc je suis ici là exactement
là où joubert pour atteindre lui parce
qu'après je pense vraiment qu'un tunnel
creusé qui sortirait là donc je vais
leur tournée je fais une rotation dans
ce sens là tu avoues sinon en ce moment
parce que moi je craque des casse tête
voilà c'est ça la bille qui étaient à
l'intérieur je sais pas ça avait un nom
c'est big hill à toutes les personnes
qui qui qui sont nés il ya peu près
mille ans comme moi dans les années 80
comme on appelait ses billes là vous le
savez ou pas blasé ténor avec ça je
crois que c'était des pirates hors jeu
c'est plus j'en sais rien ok donc
forcément pour l'euro m il suffit de
mettre la bigue ici de retourner du coup
par un
les ou un truc qui me paraît pas claire
pour pour faire retomber la vie claque
et claquent et la halle est où là ah oui
c'est bon allez dans le khat donc là je
là ça risque plus rien du tout la même
ok ben c'était une affaire rondement
menée les amis pas mon préféré mais pas
de doux quand même mais rapide je suis
pas sûr qu'il se retirait pour que ça à
faire mais j'ai eu de la chance en fait
comme on tourne avec cette lumière j'ai
lumière qui est ici sur ma droite un
mois en fait ça à éclairer l'intérieur
du 1 et samassa éclairer l'intérieur du
3 et c'est ça qui m'a permis de
comprendre le tunnel et après de
remonter toute la procédure
donc donc voilà coule pas mal je le note
en pas mal mais peut mieux faire
forcément je sais jamais avant de
résoudre ce que ça va rendre mais par
contre je le fais gagner si vous le
voulez je publie cette photo aujourd'hui
même sur instagram vous l'a commenté je
fais un tirage au sort dans sept jours
et ça s'arrête chez toi mon bon ami
alors on retourne cette séquence avec
loïc parce qu'on avait déjà tourné là où
trop donc ça n'a plus rien à voir c'est
très étrange qui est en train de se
passer pour vous osiez au montage mais
on s'est dit que c'était peut-être un
peu rapide et du coup il ya toujours des
pièces d'échecs que j'ai par oseo lui
parce que plus ça va plus je les trouve
simple et moins intéressant ça voulait
faire en vidéo j'aurais dû lui faire en
faire plusieurs en même temps mais du
coup je me dis je vais peut-être essayer
de faire ce cher roi
en fait en réalité d'ailleurs raillé je
suis partie dessus là il ya un espèce de
piston d'accord ok qui des fois bloque
un peu là il ya une espèce de cette
partie là bloque aussi et après il ya
cette partie là qui bouge donc je me dis
il ya un moyen sûrement de le résoudre
assez rapide tronquée de la ses sorties
et si c'est comme tous les autre
casse-tête pièces d'échecs ça veut dire
qu'il ya un petit truc qui ressort qui
est qu'il faut réussir à le faire tomber
forcément attends je vais essayer de le
bloquer c'est comme ça il faut le mettre
d'accord parce que là clairement je
pense maintenant je commence à les
comprendre aussi c'est pour ça que
voulait plus faire des vidéos vraiment
dédié à eux mais je pense que si ce bloc
il faut que j'arrive à elle met en
position bloqué entre guillemets
et qu'après il ya une manière de le
tourner qui va le réseau de savoir qui
va il va plus me prendre date et depuis
la pièce
donc là c'est complètement mobile là je
peux me tournait à l'ena il est bloqué
gc ca quand je donne des coups que je
sens que c'est de plus en plus dur donc
j'imagine que le truc fait que de
rentrer de plus en plus à l'intérieur
[Musique]
mais bon on a put 1 c'était je croyais
que j'entendais ça et c'est ça que
j'entendais donc est ce que la théorie
était bonne est ce que ma théorie du jeu
je le tournage piste à évaluer ça en
fait quand on est comme ça
après on tourne est appuyé ouais en fait
vos pistes et voilà bon bah comme ça on
a récupéré la petite pièce comme ça
cette pièce est résolu parce qu'on se
demandait si un jour on allait vers
résoudre quelque part sur la chaîne nbc
chose faite donc ça me permet de vous
remettre la outreau qui du coup était
déjà tourné donc dans cet état où trop à
cette époque je ne savais pas qu'on
allait faire savoir bon ben c'est pour
ce que j'avais à vous dire je vous donne
rendez vous mercredi prochain six ans
plus tard bonnet vous là ici il ya un
casse tête c'est le casse-tête de la
semaine dernière c'est le casse tête
avec loïc le deuxième casse tête qu'on
fait ensemble avec loïc il a voulu
déménager la maison d'orage peux pas
vous en dire plus à très bientôt
ciao